تستضيف لتلخيصها نستضيف معنا الان في هذه
النافذه وزير الخارجيه
الباكستاني بلا والبوت زرداري اهلا وسهلا
بك
[موسيقى]
سيد بلال
طبعا انت الان خرجت من اجتماعات كنت
مشاركا فيه
هذا المؤتمر التقيت بنظرك الالماني بناظرك
الصيني بنظرك الاوكراني وبناظرك السعودي
وكانت لك مجموعه من اللقاءات ايضا مع
مسؤولين اخرين كيف تجد مؤتمر هذه السنه
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه اعتقد اني هذه
هي المره الاولى التي نجتمع فيها في هذا
المؤتمر بعد فتره الجائحه اذا اجتماع
حضوري واعتقد ان هذا المؤتمر شكل نجاح
كبيرا بالنظر لمشاركه الكثير من وزراء
الخارجيه واعتقد ان الاجنده مكثفه
[موسيقى]
نعم موضوع سيد وزير الخارجيه باكستاني
موضوع الارهاب ما زال ملف الارهاب مطروحا
في باكستان
حدثت تفجيرات حركه طالبات باكستان اتهمت
بتنفيذ تفجير دموي قتل فيه اكثر من 100
فرد من افراد الشرطه الباكستانيه في
بيشاور هذا كان الشهر الماضي قبل يومين او
ثلاثه ايضا حدث
تفجير اعتداء مسلح ضد الشرطه في كراتشي
واصابع الاحتمال الاتهام عفوا موجهه
احتمالا الى حركه طالبان باكستان كيف
تعالجون ملف الارهاب في باكستان ما هي
الحلول كيف ترون حلول ظاهره الارهاب في
باكستان
شكرا جزيلا على اثاره هذا الموضوع طبعا
بعد سقوط كابول راينا ان الارهاب عاد
لباكستانا خلال الاخيره خسرنا كما قلت
حوالي 100 عنصر
على المجتمع الدولي ان ياخذ على محمل الجد
طبعا تهديدات الارهابيه التي تنبثق من
افغانستان وعلينا ان نعمل في يد من اجل
عدم الوقوع فيه اخطاء الماضي علينا ان لا
نتراجع وعلينا ان نبقى صامدين في وجه
الارهاب ونعمل
باكستان الان تواجه طبعا ارتداد ارهاب
بالنظر لان الجار الاقرب لافغانستان على
المجتمع الدولي ان يتعامل مع هذه القضيه
بحزم
الوزير بما اننا نتحدث عن الوضع الامني في
باكستان جيش باكستان نفذ العديد من
العمليات العسكريه في المقاطعات القبليه
المحابيه لافغانستان واهلا اكثر من مره
مرارا سيطرته عليها واقام السياجا للحدود
ربما على مسافه اعتقد
2004 مئه
كيلومتر لكن برايك السيد الوزير الخارجيه
هل انتهت الحرب هل انتصرت باكستان في هذه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
قمنا بكسر الشوب شوكه الارهاب وقمنا
بالتقليل من امكانيات الارهابيين على قيام
بعمليه ارهابيه وايضا من قيام بعمليه
التجنيد
للارهابيين وحاولنا باكستان من بلد يشهد
الكثير من الهجمات الى بلد يشهد الامن
والاستقرار لكن للاسف منذ سقوط كابول قبل
سنه راينا ان هناك تزايد للانشطه
الارهابيه في باكستان لعل اخر وقوعها تلك
التي ضربت بيشاور وايضا كراتشي لكن لدينا
ثقه كبيره في الاجهزه الامنيه في باكستان
ووكالات الفاذا القانون في باكستان من اجل
التصدي لهذا الخطر نحن هزمنا الا السابق
وسنعمل على ذات الشيء في هذه المره ايضا
للاسف الارهابيون
من بعض الاحداث التي شاهدتها افغانستان
وهناك الان ربما حريه اكبر بالنسبه لهذه
المجموعات الارهابيه من اجل التامر
والتخطيط والتنفيذ العمليات الارهابيه
وهذا
يجعلنا
نعمل بعد يدا في يد من اجل الدفع ودحر
الارهابين وعلينا البناء القدرات الامنيه
من اجل ان نقوم بافشال كل هذه
المحاولات اذن علينا ان نتطور الكثير من
البنيه فيها افغانستان من اجل ان تتمكن
السلطات المحليه من
افشال المخاططات الارهابيه التي قد تنشا
من قبل القاعده او تنظيم الدوله او اي
منظمات اخرى
يعني افهم من كلامك ان هذه الحرب لم تحقق
هدفها بالكامل وهو القضاء على الارهاب لكن
هنا هناك من يرى انكم دفعتم ثمنا بلا
مقابل في هذه الحرب التي تقودها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
نحن طبعا قمنا به هزيمه
المتطرفين داخل باكستان وقمنا بالتحقيق
طبعا نوع من الان الاستقلال لفتره معينه
لكن بعد انسحاب امريكا وقوات من افغانستان
هذه المجموعات الارهابيه ازدادت قوه
سياسيا
وعمليتين ايضا وعلى ارض الواقع الان
بامكانهم ان يتحركوا بشكل حار نحن تمكنا
في فتره معينه من احلال الامن لكن نحن
متفائلون
لك السيد بلال وزير خارجيه باكستان شكرا
لك